Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 15 on user-defined data types.
We're going to start out today by doing a little stream review.
We're going to read a text file that contains star information.
This is a star catalog. And so we're going to open and read the input file.
And so we're going to look at stars.txt. Now in the input file, we'll see several different values.
Let's just go ahead and do that right now. So we're in lecture 15 and I have opened the starcat.cpp here.
I'm going to put my name on it. And I'm also going to open up stars.txt so I can see the data file that I'm reading.
So you notice that I have three doubles starting each line of text.
And those represent the location in space of that particular star.
That number is followed by an integer, 28 here in this first case.
This is called the Draper number. The Draper number. What it is, it's a catalog identifier.
In a star catalog, kind of like the Dewey Decimal number you'd have on a book in the library.
Following that, we have a third double. Let me go take a look right here.
4.61. And this represents the magnitude or brightness of the star.
Following that, we have another identifier, that integer 3.
And that represents a different catalog number in a catalog called the Harvard catalog.
So this number is called the Harvard Revised number.
Now some stars, like this star on line 6, and this star on line 7, have a string at the end of it. Some kind of name.
Those are what we call the name stars. If you scroll through them, you may recognize some of the stars.
Let's see if I can find one I recognize. I don't actually recognize any of those names.
Here's Polaris. I recognize the North star.
Now the stars that have a name may actually have two names.
They may have a Latin name and a common name and so forth.
Or they may just have a common name. And if they have two names, the first name is ended with a semicolon, like that.
So our job here today is to read the stars and print only the name stars. Print the primary name, a comma, an X and a Y in space.
We're going to skip the Z and the magnitude.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So let's go to StarCat. As I mentioned, you want to put your name. And I'm going to move that over there just to kind of clear up the screen.
So the catalog number is coming in as a string and we want to open it.
We've included fstream here so we know how to open file streams.
So we're going to create an input file stream. And I have stream. I'll call it in.
And I'm going to open it with cat name.
Now, if we can't open the file, then we want to print an error message and exit.
So if in fail, CR cannot open cat name, capital N on cat name.
And since this is a void function, I'm just going to return.
Ok, now let's read the file. So basically, notice that every line has X, Y, Z, a Draper number, a magnitude, and a Harvard number.
So that means I need to create variables for that, right?
So I'm going to say double X, Y, Z, magnitude. Those are my four doubles.
And Harvard and Draper. Or Draper and Harvard. Let me put them in the order they're in.
And to read the file using streams, I just use formatted input.
So while in X, Y, Z, Draper number's next, so make sure you don't put magnitude there.
Then the magnitude. And then the Harvard number.
Ok, well that's true.
So this will process some of the file. So let's go to the top of this text file.
So that would process that line.
And then, when we read the next line, that would process it. That would process the next line.
That would process this amount of data in line six.
But when we came around again, this is what it would read for X.
And what would happen when it tried to read that? It would stop working.
So we have to see if there's any extra text at the end of each line.
So after we've read the numbers off from the line, we're going to have to create a variable.
So string line. I'll call it rest.
So string rest and get line in rest.
So when we finish reading this first line, we've read the three,
there is still an invisible new line sitting out here waiting to be read.
And we haven't displayed that yet.
We could turn on with the editor. I'm sure there's a way to display these hidden files.
I'm not displaying them right now.
But there's a new line.
And so get line reads everything up to, including the new line, to clear off to go to the next line.
Now that's not important if we don't have a string, but if it is a string, we want to read that.
Alpha Hertz or cath semicolon space casp beta.
And so what we want to do now is after we've read the rest of the line, we want to see if it's if it's not empty.
So if rest if not rest empty.
That means I have a first name, a name one and possibly a name to possibly a name to.
So we're going to need to use those. Actually, I'm going to use them only inside here.
So let me move that down here.
So because I'm only going to print the name stars, which means that I only need to print inside this if statement.
If it's if it's not a name star, I'm not going to print it.
So let me create a couple of variables. String name one, name two.
Let me find out if there's a semicolon. So size T pause or auto pause equals rest.
Find a semicolon.
Now, two possibilities. One possibility is that it is set to string in pause.
So if pause is equal to string colon colon and pause.
In other words, it wasn't found. That means we have one name.
So name one equals rest substring.
Why? Why substring one? Because in this case where I have one, notice when I do get line, that'll be space alpha hertz.
Right. Because there's always a space at the end of the Harvard number.
And so name two will just be the empty string.
If that's not the case, I have two names. So name one equals rest substring starting at position one and going up to pause.
And name two equals rest substring starting at pause plus one.
No, no, actually starting at pause plus two. If we started at pause plus one.
So here's pause, right? We started at pause plus one. I'd have a space in front of the second name.
And I don't want that. So I'm starting at pause plus two. So I only have CAS beta inside there.
OK, so we know that this is extracted the name part of it. Now we're going to print the primary name. Name one.
X and a Y and the magnitude.
So I'm going to say C out. Name one. Comma space parenthesis.
X comma space or comma space. Y.
Right print. A comma, a space and the magnitude.
Print a new line. We might want to bring that down to two lines.
I don't know where you want to split it. Maybe right there.
Maybe that'll look a little bit better.
Now if we do make run, it'll just call our function star cat and pass in stars dot text.
So let's just do alt L.
Oh, you can't do alt L. This is the new version of the IDE. So we have to come over here to A, open a terminal there.
And then let's go ahead and do make run.
And here we have the name. We've read the entire catalog of stars. We have the name, X, Y and the magnitude of each of those stars.
So make run just does it all. Make test tests to make sure that you've actually done it correctly.
So if we do make test.
Notice that it will test several different things. It looks like make test, some of them are failing.
So if we read that. If you read O zero. Oh, it looks like we're actually getting a semicolon after our name.
OK, for some of those stars that have two names. So we have some debugging to do on that.
So name one, pause.
Does this look like pause minus one?
I think it does, because if we want to pause, we're not counting for the fact that we're starting here from one.
So that's what testing is for, to make sure that you got all of them correct.
And I have some inputs here that in fact should have been Polaris, but in fact was Polaris semicolon.
Should have been Ruchba, in fact was Ruchba with a semicolon.
Let's try it again.
OK, so that passes all of the tests. That looks OK.
All right, so let's go on now and get to today's topic.
So what we have here is each line in stars.txt consists of related information, related information.
The X and the Y and the Z about one particular star.
And just to print out that data, variables work fine. But what if I wanted to gather up all the information about a star
and pass it to a bunch of functions that would analyze different characteristics of those stars?
Well, simple variables aren't flexible enough for this.
What we need is we need a way to package up all the parts into some kind of more complex structured data of different types.
So in computer science and in programming languages, we call such structured types records.
And in C++, records are called structures or the keyword is struct we'll use to create them.
So basically, it's just a collection of data where each collection represents one item of a particular user defined kind, like a star in this case.
We say that the data is heterogeneous, meaning that we can have integers and strings and doubles all together wrapped up in one record.
It doesn't need to be all of the same type like an array does.
We say that it's accessible, meaning that we can directly access each of the parts.
So here's the syntax for creating a structure definition.
It's the keyword struct instead of class.
The name of the struct, which we call formally a structure tag, but other than me formally telling you this, we'll just call it the structure name.
Inside the structure, we have named members.
So members are like variable definitions, but they're not actually variable definitions.
They're potential variable definitions.
So notice I've named one PID, the person ID.
I've named one name.
I've named one DOB.
And notice that the structures can be the built-in types, library types, or other structured types.
Now this might look like creating a class in Java and adding data members or adding instance variables.
It's very, very similar.
We don't use the keywords public or private here in front of the things like you would do in Java.
But there's one difference that's going to trip you up.
That difference is in C++, we always need to put a semicolon at the end of the structure definition.
In Java you don't. In C++ you must.
Now, structures are a new user-defined type.
They're a definition.
They're a definition for a type.
They're not a definition for a variable.
So since they're a definition for a type, we usually place that definition in a header file.
Now there's a problem though.
What if that header file was included twice?
It's an error if the definition is included twice, is seen twice.
Your code will not compile.
And so just like we did with functions, we'll use header guards to prevent that.
So let's go ahead and add our structure definition to stars.h.
And this is the definition I'm going to use.
Struct star. I'm going to put all my doubles together just like I had them in the file.
My two integers together and my two strings.
So all of this data will store the data about one star.
So we're simply going to change this program.
We're going to add the structure definition in stars.h.
So I'm going to say struct star.
I'm going to open and close it and put the semicolon on all at once so I don't forget it.
I'm going to add the data members, so double, x, y, z, magnitude, int draper, Harvard,
and standard string, name one and name two.
So notice my header file already includes this.
And remember in a header file we cannot use using namespace standard.
So for a structure, if you want to use a type, just like for a prototype in header file,
you have to fully qualify the library type.
So there is our star structure.
What can we do with that star structure?
Well, what we can do is we can create variables of that type.
So if you have a type, its purpose is to create variables.
These are called structure variables.
Like primitive types, such variables are uninitialized.
So star a and b, both of them would be star objects with x, y, z, and so forth.
But x, y, z, and all the other members would be set to random numbers.
The two names, name one and name two, would be okay.
They'd be the empty string.
So you can initialize such a variable in several ways.
One, you can give it the default value.
So just when you create the variable, put the curly braces after it,
and that will default initialize it.
In other words, all the x's and y's will be zero.
You can aggregate initialize it, meaning you supply a value for each of the data members.
So in this case, x is .873, y is .032, z is .486, magnitude is 2.07.
The Draper number is .358, the Harvard number is 15, name one is Rigel, name two is Beta.
Now, notice that the order that you put the data members depends on the order that the data members are defined in the structure.
Notice that this order is different than what we read the data in.
Notice that we read x, y, z, then the Draper number,
but in the structure we put the x, y, z and the magnitude all together.
And so that's the way you have to initialize it.
Finally, we can initialize it one third way.
If we have another star, we can either assign to it or we can copy initialize it.
In other words, I can create a star E and it will have the same values that star C has.
Now, structures can contain other structures, so if we create some useful, say, utility structures,
a point 3D that has x, y, and z, a names structure that contained a couple of names,
and a catalog structure that contained two catalogs, we could then use these structures inside another structure.
We could nest them and we could define our star like this.
So, this might be a little bit more readable.
You can see what those x, y, and z represent, the location, then the magnitude,
then the catalog numbers, and then the names of the stars.
So, this might be a little bit more readable.
Now, to access the data members, we simply use the dot operator,
very similar to what you do in Java if you had a public instance variable.
So, if I want to access the name in the structure variable A, I just say a.name1 or a.name2.
You can also print it out, of course. So, just the name of the structure variable,
and then the name of the data member inside the structure variable.
For a nested structure, you just keep adding dots.
So, you remember I created a structure, a different star structure that had a location in it.
So, s.location would bring back a .3D structure, and then I'd select x out of it.
So, I'm selecting members from a structure using the dot, the member selection operator.
You can also assign and copy entire structure variables.
You cannot compare them. You can assign them and copy them.
So, let's go ahead and modify our star cat to use our structure variable
instead of the individual variables we used before.
So, let's come back to star cat.
First, let's come up here and say I want to include stars.h.
Notice now my program knows about the user defined type.
So, instead of these variables on line 21 and 22, I can create a star variable.
So, I can say star s.
So, I no longer have individual variables. I have them grouped together in this record.
Now, when I read them, these parts, these members are inside the variable s.
So, I'd say sx, sy, sz, sdraper, smagnitude, and sharper.
Now, notice that when I do this, these are in the order that the members are defined inside the stars.txt file,
not the order they're defined inside the structure.
So, this extracts it from the text file and puts it in the structure.
So, even though x, y, z, and magnitude are together, we don't read the magnitude before the draper number
because in the text file, the draper number appears first.
So, we're going to get the rest from the file.
And if it's not empty, so first, notice we have a name1 and name2,
but we want to make sure that every time we come through here,
since I'm not reading into name1 and name2,
every time I come through here, I reset name1 and name2.
So, s.name1 = s.name2, and both of those are going to be equal to the empty string.
Okay, so I no longer need this line on line 32, right there, name1 and name2.
And so, I'm going to say if I find this semicolon, then s.name1 is that,
and s.name1 and s.name2.
And when I print them out, finally, I'm printing out s.name1, s.x,
s.y, and s.magnitude.
Okay, so let's try that out.
And all we're going to do is do make test again.
Okay, and we still got 100%, so in this case,
we're not using the individual variables.
We have encapsulated all of the variables into this single star object right here,
this single star.
Now, probably most of you are thinking, "Well, yeah, so what?
That didn't seem any better."
But now that we've encapsulated the data inside the structure,
we can write functions that take and produce structure variables.
And so that's our next step.
So for our next step, what we want to do is write functions that take structures.
Now, in the C language, where structures were developed,
they were known as second-class types.
That's because they don't always act the same way as the built-in types.
The built-in types are the natives.
The second-class types don't have all the features of the built-in types.
So if A and B are structure variables, say stars,
this would be illegal if A and B are structure types.
But the built-in types get to do this.
And so we can fix this by writing functions to supply the missing operations.
So I could write a method called equals, and I could say if equal A, B,
and get back true and false, and use that instead.
So we can pass structure variables to functions.
We can also write a function that returns a structure.
We're going to use the same rules for variable passing as for strings.
So structure types we're going to pass by reference or const reference.
We'll never pass structure types by value.
So if I wanted to write my equal function that I would use in place of this,
that the first-class types do, I'd pass a const string ref A and a const string ref B.
And if they were equal, I'd return true in that case.
So we're going to do that.
We're going to write some functions to print and read star objects.
And so my print function is going to take the stream that I'm going to read from,
and a write to, and a star that I'm going to display.
And it's going to return the stream after it's done.
And my read function is going to take the stream I'm going to read from,
and a star by reference that I'm going to fill in when I read.
Now, notice the functions are returning the modified stream so we can test it.
In other words, I want to be able to do this.
I want to say I have stream in stars.text, star.s, and I'll read in s.
So for our next exercise, let's do in B, let's prototype and implement these two functions, print and read.
Then we'll uncomment the first section of run and do make run.
So let's close these.
Let's open B.
Let me right click it.
Open it in the integrated terminal there.
And we'll have stars.h and stars.cpp.
Put your names in stars.cpp.
And then in stars.h, notice I already have my struct star.
I already have my struct star.
I've included string and iostream.
So let's just put in the prototypes for those two functions.
So for my print function, it's an ostream ref.
But I'm inside a header file.
I can't use using namespace standard.
So the compiler is not going to understand that.
So I have to write standard colon ostream ref.
Print is the name of the function.
It's going to take a standard ostream ref for the output.
And it's going to take a const star ref s for the star.
And for our input, it's going to take a standard iostream ref.
We're going to call the function read.
I'm going to take an iostream ref in as my input stream.
And this time I'm going to take a star by reference s.
Okay, so there's my two prototypes.
Let's copy the two prototypes.
Let's move them over to stars.cpp.
Let's put a body on it.
Remove the semicolon.
And let's return the output stream and the input stream.
Okay, now I haven't done any reading or printing in here.
So what do we need to do to read from output?
Basically we need to do what we did back up in A.
So notice I have a star here.
Now I'm going to print it exactly like we printed it before.
So I'm going to say out name one, comma, space.
It's not name one, is it?
It's s.name one.
And s.x, a comma and a space, and s.y.
And a closing parenthesis and a comma and a space.
And s.magnitude.
Now we don't want to use a new line like we did when we were printing it out ourselves.
When you call the print function, they'll use the new line on it at that point.
They'll use the new line on it at that point.
Now to read the data, we have a star object here.
I have start there, of course it should be a star.
You can see the difference in the coloring here.
And did I make that mistake over in the header file?
Yeah, I did.
So that should be a star, not a start.
So to read, what we're going to do is we're going to say in s.x, s.y, s.z.
Even though we're not printing z, we still need to read it.
s.draper, s.magnitude, and s.harvard.
We need to set the name one and name two to nothing.
So s.name1 equals s.name2 equals the empty string.
Then we need to put exactly the same code we had before.
So if we need to read, we need to do git line in.
We need to create a string, I'll call it name.
So now if that name has something in it, we need to transfer it to our strings.
So if not name empty, or let me write it the other way, it's probably more easier for you.
So if name not equal to that, the name's not empty, we're going to say auto pause equals name find.
Notice this time we used double quotes, you can use double quotes or single quotes there.
So if pause equals equals string end pause, if it's not found, that means we only have one name.
So if pause equals equals end pause, it means we only have one name.
So, and I think I did this wrong in the last exercise we did in A.
So I'm going to say s.name1 equals name substring.
Let's put that up here so it's a little easier to read.
And if that's not the case, name1 equals name substring1 and pause minus 1.
Again, to count for the space at the beginning of it.
And whenever I have two lines, I don't like to put two statements on one line.
I only use one line here when I can fit the whole thing on the side there.
So name2 equals name substring pause plus 2.
And we're going to return in.
So let's come down here and let's uncomment part 1 here.
So notice we're opening stars.txt, we're creating a star, and we're calling the read function.
While read in, if not name empty and s magnitude greater than 6, print cout s.
And we're printing an end out at the end of that.
So notice that this is, this code right here, is almost the same thing as star cat that we did in part A.
In other words, because we have functions now, we've been able to compress it down to these two pieces.
And so it's much easier to read, much more flexible, much easier to use.
So let's try that. Let's do make run.
Okay, so name1, so I have a syntax error there, and name2.
And of course, that's because this is not name1, right?
It's s.name1 and s.name2.
Let me clear it and run it again.
Okay, so these are all the stars that are named that have a magnitude greater than 6.
So again, writing functions, you can see how easy it is to use them after you've written the function.
And how easy it is to use it after you've written the function.
Now, it would be nicer if we could use the regular operators for our output.
In other words, if there was no difference between a star and printing an int, that's what we're shooting for.
And so for any user-defined type, you can overload most of the C++ operators to work with that type.
So we're going to be covering this many, many times in this class.
This is your first introduction to it.
So, plus, equals, equals, greater than, all of those are called binary operators.
Because we have a plus b, the operator plus takes two operands, the a and the b.
One's on the left-hand side, one's on the right-hand side.
The same through equals, equals, greater than, and so forth.
So the syntax is whatever the return type, so greater than returns a bool, equals, equals returns a bool.
Plus would return whatever type this object type is.
So it could be an int, it could be a double, it could be a star.
And so it's the return type, say bool, the operator, and then the symbol used for the operator.
The symbol used for the operator, so operator greater than, operator equals, equals.
And then the two arguments that will appear on the left-hand side and the right.
So LHS here just means the left-hand side, RHS just means the right-hand side.
And again, we replace the question mark here with the operator symbol.
So, suppose we wanted to compare star operators by magnitude.
If we wanted to do that, we'd use the less than operator.
So notice the function is named operator less than.
Less than returns a bool, true or false.
Would take two const stars, so const star ref LHS, const star ref RHS.
And then would return true if the magnitude of the left-hand side was less than the magnitude on the right-hand side.
Now, what we'd like to do now is we'd like to overload the input and output operators.
So the output operators have this prototype.
Now, that should look familiar to you as well as that one.
The only difference between read and print and these operators is the name of the function.
So, almost exactly the same signature as print and read, but with different names.
And so we can implement those by using read and print to implement them.
So we're going to go ahead and do that.
We're going to complete our second exercise here by adding these two member functions,
or these two overloaded operators to our code.
So in stars.h, we're going to take, make a copy of these two.
And I'm simply going to name this one operator output.
It's an O-string.
And this one I'm going to name operator input.
It's an I-string.
So notice that I used exactly the same prototype, just with a different name.
I'm going to copy it over to stars.cpp.
I'm going to paste them up here.
Remove the semicolon.
Remove the semicolon here.
And since we've already implemented that functionality as a function, I can just say return print out s.
And for this one I can just say return read in s.
So I'm using these functions up here that we wrote by hand to implement our overloaded operators.
And if you come down to run, now we can go ahead and comment out the remainder of this.
The remainder of that. And we should be able to do make run again.
And notice that the input and output operators work perfectly fine.
And reading from a string works perfectly fine.
So we can pass a string stream, you notice, for this third part.
I've just created an I-string stream with some values in it.
I pass it to read and it works perfectly fine.
And the input operators, so notice for part two here, rather than saying while read in s, I'm saying while in arrow s.
And here I'm saying cout arrow arrow s.
So I'm using exactly the same syntax.
So to finish this up, make sure the run part works.
Go ahead and just do make test.
And it will test running and looking at several different kinds of stars.
Testing individually the output operator to make sure that it's correct.
Testing individually the input operator.
Again, this is what the input is. Here's one with two names.
We test it with one name. Test it with one with no name.
So we can test all those possibilities.
And this is just testing read and print separately.
So here's testing read. Here's testing print.
Here's testing the input operator. Here's testing the output operator.
Okay, so structured types are things like the date that you see on the right.
It has January 3rd, 2009.
It has a string and a couple of integers.
So that's a structured type.
We can also create user defined scalar types.
Ones that have only a single value versus the structured type or the record that adds multiple values together.
With scalar values, we can enumerate, meaning we can list or count each possible value.
For instance, if I want to create a type that represents the weekdays,
it's Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, and Friday.
Saturday and Sunday wouldn't be one of the weekdays.
We can write this two ways.
In C++11, we use the words "anum" followed by "class".
So anum, class, weekday.
These are called scoped enumerations.
They were introduced again in C++11.
C++ and C, the older version of C++, that's what's called a plain enumeration.
You generally want to use the scoped enumerations because they have less opportunities for errors.
So let's look at defining an enumerated type.
So an enumerated type is a set of related integer values which act like a type.
You provide a name for each value.
For example, the suit values for a deck of cards would include the clubs, the spades, the diamonds, and the hearts.
Now notice the names are separated by commas.
There's no ending semicolon. There's an ending semicolon at the end of the definition of the type.
But there's no semicolon after the word "hearts".
So no ending semicolon.
You should use lowercase or propercase. Avoid using uppercase.
Here are some of the things you can do with a scoped enumeration.
I could create a suit variable, S, an enumerated type variable.
I could initialize it. What would I initialize it with?
I'd initialize it not with hearts, but with its fully qualified name, suit colon colon hearts.
I could compare it to another enumerated type.
I couldn't compare it to an integer, but I could compare it to suit clubs using not equals and equals.
Now greater than and less than also kind of works, but it's not very, very useful.
So generally we'll use equals or not equals.
We can use that variable as a switch selector.
So switch S, case suit clubs, return clubs. Case suit hearts, return hearts.
So this is converting a suit type into a string type.
If it wasn't one of the four clubs, which are the only things it could possibly be,
would return some kind of error or have an assertion there or throw an exception, something like that.
So why do we want to use enumerated types?
Consider a playing card.
A playing card has two things.
It has a suit and a rank.
We could represent that suit and that rank like ace, king, queen, jack is the rank,
and diamonds, hearts, spades, and clubs are the suits.
We could represent those by using strings or integers or something else.
So imagine if we represented the rank and the suit using strings.
There should be a comma between rank and suit here,
and I will probably fix that on the slides that you'll see if you click the slides.
Then I go and create a card object.
And I create a card A and I pass it ace and clubs.
Well, what's the problem?
Well, cubs is the wrong spelling for the clubs,
so instead of the ace of clubs, I get something that doesn't make any sense.
In other words, my type is not very resilient.
The compiler can't check the fact that I've passed the wrong values.
Suppose instead I decide to make rank and suit integers.
And then I create some constants like this, ace 101 and clubs 1001.
So I start all the ranks at 1 and I start all the suits at 1000.
And then I try and create a card B, clubs ace.
Well, what's the problem?
Again, my structure has rank and suit.
What I've passed in is 1001 for the rank and 101 for the suit.
Both of those are invalid values, and I would have to do some extra checking.
Again, the compiler can't check to see that I have switched my rank and suit,
where it's supposed to be rank suit, and I've passed in clubs.
I've passed in suit and rank.
Again, the compiler can't change that.
Suppose, however, that I created an enumerated type for the rank,
an enumerated type for the suit.
Then I would create it like this, card rank ace, rank clubs.
If I switch those, the compiler would tell me.
I would know the moment I tried to compile my code, I've made a mistake.
I would not have to ever worry about creating a card object with invalid values.
It would be impossible.
And so that's really why we want to use enumerated types.
We say that we're creating strong types for our arguments and our parameters.
Now, there is no built-in input/output with enumerated types.
You may write a two-string function.
You may want to convert it to a string for output with a function.
So here's a two-string function that takes a rank.
We'll switch on the rank, and then case rank ace, we'll return ace.
Case rank two, we'll return two. Case rank three, we'll return three.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So for our exercise here with enumerated types,
we're going to take the coin type and we're going to complete the two-string function for the coin type.
So let me close that.
Let me close this. Let me close this.
Let's go down to C.
And this will be in enumH.
So here's our enumerated type.
And we're going to write the two-string function.
And let's see if we want to do the two-string and the value of function.
So actually we're going to write two functions in this.
And so this is in enumOps.cpp.
So let's put your name in here.
Notice I've included enum.h right here.
I'm going to put my name at the top of this just to get the practice.
So I'm going to put summer22 for this.
Okay, let's go grab those two prototypes.
And we'll see how we would add our implementation for that right here.
Okay, so if I want to convert a coin object to string, I'm going to have to use a switch statement.
So I'm going to have to say switch on C.
Now I'm going to have to say case coin colon colon and then what the coin types are.
So what are my coin types?
I'll just copy them right here.
So case coin penny colon.
So that's the structure.
The colon colon and the colon is kind of confusing here.
I'm going to return penny.
And this will be case coin dime, case coin quarter, case coin nickel.
Let's put the colons on the end of each of those case labels.
So here we're going to return nickel.
Here we're going to return a dime.
Here I'm going to return a quarter.
And here I'm going to return half dollar.
Okay, what if it is none of those?
Well, technically it has to be one of those.
I believe the code will compile without us putting a default in it.
Let's just try it.
Let's open up a shell on that.
Let's just do make on it.
Okay, value of, okay, control reaches end of non-void function.
So it does require us to do something.
And so what we could do here is we could just add an assert or a throw or just a return.
Or you could add a throw statement.
A throw would work fine.
And we could put this, of course, inside the default.
In which case we don't need it here.
It's maybe a little more obvious over there that that is an error in that case.
Okay, so now we've got a coin and we want to get its value.
Now we could do a switch like this, case coin penny, return one.
Case coin nickel, return two.
But notice when I created my enumerated type,
I provided an underlying value for each of the types that represents the type of the value.
Now we want to return it as a double.
And so what we're going to need to do is we're going to need to cast this to its underlying type.
So I'm going to say static return static cast double C divided by 100.
And this actually should be, you should cast it to an int, not a double.
So static cast int divided by 100 will give us a double.
And that should, in fact, pass all our tests.
Make works, so make test.
And to string, oh, it wanted half dollar to look slightly different, so let's fix that.
It wants it to look like that.
So let's say make test.
Okay, so all of these work.
Okay, so this was converting a type, an enumerated type to a two string,
so we could do output on it and a value of,
so we could use it in a calculation, a coin type rather than an integer.
I could use it with other types.
Okay, the last thing we want to look at today in this lecture is we want to look at I/O operators.
So I've already seen these I/O operators for stars.
We have const star ref.
We can use them for any user defined types, including for enumerated types.
So we're going to use the two string for rank and suit.
Card, of course, is a structure in this case,
so we can use the output operators for our cards just like we did with our stars.
The input operator looks like this, just like the ones we used for stars.
Our input is going to be in the form of AS for ace of spades, TH for ten of hearts,
JC for jack of clubs, and so forth.
So this is our last exercise. We're going to write the card I/O operators down in,
let's close that,
down in D.
So let's open a shell on that.
And let's close the previous shells.
And so I only have one shell open on D.
Let's open card I/O dot CVP. This is the one we're going to change.
Cards dot H, I believe, already has our prototypes inside there.
So we can just copy those prototypes, that's what we're going to write.
It has these functions already written, the two string for the suit and the two string for the rank.
So the output one is pretty easy.
The output one, we're simply going to say out, two string, C dot rank.
Then we're going to put of, and two string, C dot suit.
And then we're going to return out.
So that's pretty easy. We're taking two string, and again, that's already defined for us here.
And here are the types for suits and ranks.
So we don't need to use a switch statement for that.
This is our structure for our card. It has a rank and a suit.
So the output is pretty easy. The input is a little more difficult.
So we're going to return in at the end of this.
We're going to need to read two characters.
So I'm going to call those R and C.
So char R and C.
And we're going to need to read in R and C.
Now there is no easy way to compute, convert R to C, other than writing a switch.
So we're going to write switch R, and then switch C.
Now the parts that make up a rank, let's just go copy them over here.
There's our suit.
So let me just copy both of those over here.
Okay, so here's our ranks.
Now that's our suits.
Let's paste them in there and comment them out.
Here's our ranks.
And I should have called this R and S, right? Rank and suit.
Okay, so there's my ranks.
Here's my suit.
Okay, so let's put the syntax in there.
So case rank colon colon ace.
What we're going to say is C rank equals.
Of course, let me put this. I'm really messing this up.
Case ace, then C.rank equals rank.ace and break.
Okay, so we're going to do the same thing. I'm just going to copy that code there.
Let's put in all the ranks.
Two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Can't put ten as a character, so we're going to use T.
Jack, queen, and one more.
King.
So this is going to be.
So that's going to be two. Three. Four. Five. Six. Seven. Eight.
Oops.
Eight. Nine. Ten. Jack. Queen. King.
And let's put a default.
Let's throw an exception.
Throw a string.
Throw a bad rank.
Okay, now let me copy one of these lines here.
We'll use the same thing for the suit.
Although, of course, it's much closer. It's very shorter.
So the suits are going to be spades, clubs, C suit.
That should be C, right?
And this is going to be suit clubs.
And we can just make. I'm not quite sure what I did.
So here's spades, diamonds, hearts.
And this, of course, is S, D, and H.
And we'll do the same thing for the default.
I'll just throw a bad suit instead of a bad rank.
Okay, let's try it here.
So let's do make.
And let's do make test.
Okay, so here's my output operator. I created this car with rank of ace.
It prints out ace of spades.
Queen of hearts. Jack of diamonds.
Now I've created a, I've got in seven of clubs.
If you want to see what I'm processing, I'm processing this file.
Seven of clubs, two of diamonds, ten of diamonds, ten of clubs, queen of hearts.
And if we look at the output,
what we got is seven of clubs, two of diamonds, ten of diamonds, ten of clubs, queen of hearts.
So that worked just perfectly.
Okay, so we went a little over an hour today.
But we covered structured types and enumerated types.
And you were introduced to overloaded operators.
I'll see you in lecture 16.